good citizens of the reject Nation I am koi genre
and I am very excited for this very trailer I have
waited all year we're two weeks after the end
of the year and it's finally here how you doing
John I I am I am excited too sir and I'm happy
to be here with you ready for across the spider
verse it's on now Greg is not here because he is
across the country about to be wed we don't leave
till tomorrow but that means this is also likely
our last trailer reaction of the year because you
know betrothal but what a perfect one it's time
to get after it please leave a like very important
hit that subscribe Bell leave a comment let us
know your favorite part of the trailer spoiler
alert is going to be Miguel O'Hara Oscar Isaac
about to own very excited let's get into it
I'm still shocking excited dude no dude
I can hear you being quiet mom oh I am hope
I didn't ice your game man no one my age says
those words in that order it's just hard to see
my little man not be my little boy all the time
for years I've been taking care of this little boy
uh-huh
making sure he is loved
that he feels like he belongs
wherever he wants to be
he wants to belong to the
world and do great big things
not bad kid I like the new suit and what
I worry about most that's gorgeous shoes
they won't look out for you like us I love
the mood yeah want to get out of here every
texture where do you go from here you have to
promise to take care of that little boy for me
make sure you never oh cool oh my God The
Citadel spiders he never doubts that he's loved
and he never lets anyone tell him that he doesn't
you gotta promise miles I promise
dang oh really yeah
aggressive lines in Spider-Man 299 is perfect that
is like it's such an overwhelming trailer I was
like silent it was just I know I I feel like we
we I need to watch it there was so much going on
play it back that was incredible yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah just like off the bat the combination
of both mood and emotion but with all the you know
spider-verse Madness that you want like I I love
that they kind of they took me off guard with
how they approached the mood of this trailer it
was solemn it almost felt like uh like a legacy
trailer for a movie like five into a franchise
I don't know when you're like we're gonna look
back at some times we've had like it was a very
heavy trailer yeah it feels like like at the point
later on in a franchise where you're like no no we
got to make this like really emotional and heavy
because our characters are getting mature by this
point which isn't like unfitting for you know a
coming-of-age journey as miles is still on but
and just the the shot they've chosen like I love
that this is some Redemption for Spider-Man losing
Gwen in life like so the Multiverse get spider
going with miles but like that Spider-Man Gwen
connection is so beautiful always but specifically
theirs like this is such a great rom-composter
yeah oh that's a good point you know what I mean
like it's so special for this character set I love
his new costume uh I think the blend of I mean we
saw at least five animation Styles not to mention
all the Spider-Man had their own animation style
like their own Universe was formatted to them
seemingly first of all I feel like we definitely
saw the Spider-Man from the video game voiced by
Yuri and then I think I saw like police cop uh
which is a voice thing I think Yuri did for the
Spider-Man game as well so you're gonna have like
Easter egg on Easter egg within the game I think
I saw Spider-Man Unlimited the Animated Series um
pretty sure I saw spider monkey in a later frame
on the top left I thought I saw a spider with
a tail I think it's spider monkey spider monkey
very likely good sir nor do I say man spider and
there was a man spider in there he's a man spider
there's a man supposed at least not not maybe all
the same colors there was definitely a Spider-Man
with six to eight arms and then like a werewolfy
spider uh and then I saw I do believe a Spider-Man
uh like superior Spider-Man suit which mirrors
the Scarlet Spider uh talking to the Spider-Man
from the video game uh I hope that's your it's
got to be Yuri uh and we got Bag Man bag man I
got my Funko Pop back man huge moment okay so
we can break down those things forever but uh
certain key moments jump out we talked about
tone but feelings yeah I mean this this caught
me off guard in a lot of different ways again
like we said the somber tone him talking to
his mom which I thought was a great great wrap
around like I really like that they chose to go
with a lot of silence and then yeah going through
this like Nexus web like part of me was expecting
like oh we're gonna go Multiverse hopping in a
trailer like this but even the teaser trailer
didn't quite do that either it more focused in
on him and Gwen this one focuses in on him and
his mom and so I love that spider like what
made the first movie so great is that it is
magnificently personal and it's a real character
story but it has all this imagination and all
this craziness and all these worlds and spider
folk and all sorts of stuff and so like that is
present here but I like that they are using some
restraint with all the places we could go and whom
we might see we're we're seeing this like web of
Spider-Man and at all you know and that's kind of
expansive enough because through that I can feel
the promise of all the other places we might end
up and so I like that they keep a good amount of
surprise in the anticipation based off this but
are also giving you a ton to look forward to in
all these different iterations of the character
yeah so I'm I'm really uh thrilled and enthralled
by the sort of left of center approach they took
with this and I can't wait to see what the
movie delivers on because now I'm not only
hyped first Spider-Man 2099 and all this hijinks
but also like to see miles continue growing as a
character dude this is not out till May and they
just gave us this so but I think those are really
smart to use about a minute of footage in a two
and a half minute trailer from the last film so
we are given a ton of new data but not a lot of
new footage because you can look at this and see
spider monkey you can see Spider-Man Unlimited
from the Animated Series surprise like there's
so many things they can do we're gonna bring in
other worlds other multiverses other universe that
already established but we don't know a lot and
that's great because this is far enough out I love
that we don't get a lot of Spider-Man 2099 talking
I'm very excited for Oscar Isaac's betrayal he's
one of my favorite Spider-Man I'm so shocking
excited but I don't want to have too much too
soon I also love the vulture being in that very
uh almost Galileo Illustrated like you know the
old sketch style looks like it's drawn a piece of
parchment whatever is that yeah I can't wait for
that world because we've seen steampunk but we
haven't seen that and that's another element uh
and if you look at a few of the the big Nexus
you were describing it as um there's a lot of
that like one two animation where it's two frames
and the characters are moving at every other frame
yeah so like they're like as if they're drawn on
twos yeah so I think that's really interesting
I'm wondering if that Nexus what what the rules
of that world are because it's almost like their
suits are moving independent of them and then the
background moving independent of them so I wonder
if you go through and it's like slowed down if
if background's moving they're moving costumes
moving like what that element is in the animation
because this is some of the most staggering like
everything I wanted out of this and I do think
you're right I think they're gonna have this
Nexus and then in the third movie it's gonna be
more the Multiverse hopping because the last one
you have to build to something yeah and then I
you know with them bringing in animated movies
as well as uh sorry animated shows as well as the
video game I could see this tying into the Madame
Web movie and this being I was gonna make a joke
about that but I mean maybe because it is and and
you know a spider verse it wouldn't absolutely
not make sense or anything like that you know
and Jessica Drew in this I'm so excited to see
Jessica Drew uh she's fighting vulture Jessica
Drew is one of my favorite characters if you
haven't read the arc where she's like a single
mom raping a kid porcupine great stuff very
slept on character I think she's gonna be the
the surprise of this movie like Spider-Man Noir
was maybe she'll join the crew because I you know
you got Gwen and uh Jake Johnson Spider-Man in
2099 seemingly all together for this adventure
maybe they'll pull her in yeah and that pink
robe it's gonna be a lot of people on Halloween
wearing a pink robe as opposed to sweatpants
Jake B Johnson always the trendsetter Peter B
Parker Jake Johnson always a Vibe always correct
uh what did you guys think of this trailer I am
enamored I'm in love I am enthralled I am so
about it I am very excited too as soon as we
hit cut watch this frame by frame if that was
fighter monkey all right Yuri I hope you're in
this I love you let's get after it leave a comment
leave a like share stuff much love spider first
Gene the Jeter if there's anybody at this patreon
page who would be the most fitting to travel
across a Multiverse finding and recruiting all of
his different iterations it would it would easily
be you Gene I mean you already occupied so many
creative spaces you are a loving and loyal guy
but you also get a sense of adventure you know
you're always out photographing beautiful people
and taking on different kinds of challenges
with your creative expression and that's the
kind of Multiverse I want to live in you have
been a supporter of this patreon page of this
channel for so long and I just can't thank
you enough especially you know with all of
the craziness that we've dealt with behind the
scenes over the years you have been a constant
you've been one of those people especially
patreon especially with all the wackiness that
YouTube can throw your way patreon has been such
a wonderful Saving Grace and it's people like you
and koi I'll let you talk to Gene in
a second because people like you who
really warm our hearts and make us feel
loved and supported so thank you buddy
appreciate you very much might I say yes sir
great superhero name Gene Jeter alliteration
okay Peter Parkers you know your Jay Jonah
Jamesons your Miles Morales Jean Jeter right
there in the spider-verse Well Done parents of
Gene Jeter meant to be buddy happy Christmas